[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain an
action-adventure fantasy film called
d-war
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie a voice
narrates that many people think the time
of dragons is over
but in reality it has only just begun
every 500 years a woman with a mystical
spirit power is born she has the ability
to turn a serpent into the mightiest
dragon of all
the nature of the serpent will define
the fate of the world as a good serpent
will use its power to protect the
universe but an evil one will use it to
destroy the world
the voice concludes by saying that now
is the time for the spirit to be
awakened the scene cuts to an accident
site in los angeles a massive dent has
been formed on the ground and the cause
is unknown a man being escorted out
yells that a beast has risen several
police officers investigate the place
trying to collect evidence a reporter
named ethan kendrick arrives at the site
and shoots a video of a scale-like
pattern on the ground ethan is now back
in his office but cannot stop looking at
the scale it reminds him of a story his
mentor jack told him 15 years ago when
he was just a kid ethan's father once
took ethan to an antique shop that
belonged to a man named jack
there he had seen the same scale and a
strange light coming from inside a box
smoke from inside the box washes over
ethan and jack realizes what is
happening he fakes a heart attack and
sends ethan's father away to get
medicine so he can talk to ethan alone
jack then tells ethan about the legend
of imogi imogi which translates to
dragon in english are mystical creatures
who lived in heaven with their followers
every 500 years one emoji is rewarded
for their good deeds with a chance to
become a celestial dragon a dragon more
powerful than all others
but for that the emoji will have to
receive the gift of you ye jew from the
heavens 500 years ago a similar
opportunity was provided to the serpents
but among them was an evil emoji named
baraki who wanted to possess yu yi joo
for himself so he could spread his evil
to the world heaven didn't want to give
baraki such powers so they sent yu yi
jew to the earth back in 1057 yu yi joo
landed in a small village in korea
heaven then sent its best warriors bokum
and his student haram to protect the yu
yi jew from beraki however the evil
baraki wouldn't back down until he got
yu yi joo a girl named naren was born
with a tattoo on her shoulder which
meant that she was chosen to withhold yu
yi joo when naren turned 20 the yu yi
jew inside her would be completely
formed from an early age the protector
of yu yijoo bokum trained haram to
protect naren and taught him everything
he needed to know about imoogi he gave
haram a medallion that would protect him
as naren's savior eventually haram and
naren fell in love with each other the
day she turned 20 their village was
attacked by an army sent by baraki to
abduct naren they destroyed the whole
village and killed whoever got in their
way the soldiers then checked every
girl's shoulder to look for the mark and
found naren they abducted her but haram
came to her rescue and managed to take
her away to a waterfall bokum ran to the
waterfall to find haram's medallion on
the ground naren and haram had run away
together enraged and desperate to get
the yu yi jew the evil baraki pursued
them himself the two reached a cliff and
were about to get caught they jumped off
of the cliff committing suicide leaving
beraki to wait for another 500 years for
yu yi jiu to be born after telling the
story jack shows ethan a mark on his arm
claiming that he is bocom's
reincarnation and ethan is haram's
reincarnation he then hands ethan the
same medallion and tells him to always
keep it near the girl with yu yi joo has
already been sent to the earth and is
named sarah they have to find and save
her from baraki in this life as well
back in the present ethan is still in
his office he asks his colleague named
bruce to look for a girl named sarah who
was born with a dragon tattoo on her
shoulder bruce laughs saying that there
are thousands of sarah's in la the scene
cuts to sarah exercising in a gym she
and her friend watch the news and see
ethan reporting about the scale that was
found that morning the news unsettles
sarah so she quickly rushes out of the
gym meanwhile agent frank pinsky who is
investigating the finding of this scale
goes to meet a scientist studying it
they have found out that the scale is
harder than diamond and seems to be of
an ancient reptile no one has ever seen
such a substance before so they do not
have much idea about its origin sarah
has an unsettling feeling and feels like
her life is in danger her friend brandi
assumes the news from earlier just got
into sarah's head and invites her to go
out at night three thugs harass sarah on
the streets jack arrives there and
knocks the thugs out in mere seconds
before leaving somewhere else in a zoo a
zookeeper comes across the evil
emogibaraki throwing an elephant in the
air a strange man in black clothing
watches from afar the scared zookeeper
is left speechless
sarah is now at the police station
explaining how the thugs were knocked
out a reporter clicks her picture to
cover the story the reporter happens to
be one of ethan's colleagues ethan gets
a look at the picture of sarah and sees
the tattoo on her shoulder he has
finally found the girl who bears the yu
yi joo at night sarah dreams of someone
trying to kill her when she wakes up she
is troubled by a pain in her chest so
she calls 9-1-1 and paramedics escort
her to a hospital her friend brandy and
her boyfriend go to sarah's home to pack
her clothes and bring them to the
hospital but they come across the giant
serpent beraki he kills brandy in one go
and continues searching for sarah the
man from earlier who happens to be the
general of beraki's soldiers is there
too the following day ethan and bruce go
to sarah's house which is being
investigated for brandy's murder they
find out about her being in a hospital
and go to meet her ethan finally meets
sarah and tells her he is there to help
but as they talk beraki circles the
hospital looking for sarah ethan and
bruce managed to drive her away from the
hospital but are stopped by the general
however a car driven by jack saves them
the fbi is investigating beraki's attack
at the hospital and finds out that the
serpent is looking for sarah agent frank
is ordered by his boss to kill the girl
once he finds her because it is the only
way to stop beraki meanwhile the general
summons the army of beraki called the
atrox army it consists of historic
creatures like flying dragons and
dollars
jack drops ethan and sarah off at a
beach and from there they go to ethan's
psychologist friend's house the doctor
hypnotizes sarah and asks her about her
past life
sarah remembers her life as naren and
how she loved haram suddenly a blue
light shines from within her and she
starts to float in mid-air ethan calms
her down but beraki finds them there as
well they get into a car and drive away
while the massive serpent follows them
the two manage to get away from it and
call bruce they meet him at a restaurant
where bruce prepares a helicopter for
them so they can fly away somewhere safe
jack appears in front of ethan and asks
him to take the girl to the waterfall
where a good serpent can get a hold of
the yu yi jew but that would still mean
that sarah would die so ethan denies it
suddenly beraki approaches the
restaurant making ethan and sarah run
for their lives it follows them around
the city destroying everything that
comes in its way the duo manages to get
on the roof of a skyscraper where they
board a helicopter but before they can
take off the massive serpent slithers up
the building and catches the helicopter
in its mouth
ethan and sarah jump back on the roof as
the helicopter goes flying on the ground
and explodes the officials have
concluded the situation as an emergency
and sent several army choppers to fight
baraki as the choppers fire at the
creature ethan and sarah run away the
army choppers somehow get the beast off
the building but are then attacked by
the aatrox army a fleet of dragons
attacks the soldiers and soon overpowers
them massive army tanks fight the crowd
of dawdlers but are no match for the
creatures agent frank and his associate
campbell finally find sarah and ethan
and take them to a safe building however
when they reach there frank points his
gun at sarah he has been ordered to kill
her to stop the chaos
campbell shoots frank dead before he can
kill sarah he believes that only sarah
can stop the baracki from coming back
every 500 years the duo then gets in a
car and drives away from the city in
hopes of escaping but the aetrox army
finds them they are eventually abducted
and brought to beraki's building ethan
is tied to a pole while sarah is laid
for baraki to consume the yu yi jew
inside of her they are surrounded by the
aatrox army and have no way to escape
now the general summons baraki who
approaches sarah to get the yu yi jew
but suddenly a light flashes upon
ethan's medallion the medallion's power
is increased which lets out a strong
force killing the whole atrox army and
burning them to dust but the general and
baraki are left unharmed the general
strikes at ethan and an electric force
coming out of the medallion kills him
too
now an angered baraki attacks the two
but is restrained by a good emoji sent
from heaven the two serpents get into an
intense battle slithering around one
another they are matched in strength and
abilities but beraki manages to knock
out the goody moogie and approaches
sarah again seeing someone as powerful
as the goody moogie being defeated sarah
has no hope left she finally accepts her
fate and approaches beraki a bright
light shines from her tattoo and creates
a magical floating sphere the sphere is
the yu yi jew
before beraki can consume the sphere
sarah who can control it throws it
towards the good imugi the goody moogie
consumes it and turns into the mighty
dragon that baraki wished to be sarah
falls unconscious to the ground after
transforming into the dragon the goody
moogie is a thousand times more powerful
than beraki it strikes it buraki and
throws it to the ground easily the
dragon then tries to go back to heaven
but beraki latches onto its tail the
dragon attacks it with fire and finally
kills the beast it then approaches ethan
holding sarah and throws out yu yi joo
from its mouth
sarah's body turns into a magical smoke
and forms the shape of her eternal self
she tells ethan that they will meet
again someday and gets sucked into yu yi
joo the mighty dragon consumes the yu yi
jew and flies away to heaven
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you